all right so an amazing thing
happened today at this bhs championship
where you got the likes of naka fedo
saif
carlson uh
all kinds of people playing this thing
this is the semi-finals as i understand
them
but the amazing thing to me isn't just
this tournament we could talk forever
about it what i want to focus in
on is something that happens today that
maybe it's some kind of record it but
it's definitely pretty interesting and
that is that
naca destroyed fedo saif
in this blitz thing and uh
let me just describe the format a little
bit they play eight games
at i believe it's five five so five
minutes
with a five second increment and then
they
get faster and faster and um
like three one and then one one one one
being one minute with one second
increment
and um let's make sure we're going on
here
so the remarkable thing
about it is that
the first bit of it the five five
carlson
one 8-0 totally stunning
totally stunning um
and uh let's make sure we got this here
totally stunning development what i want
to do
is i want to go through these games
and just kind of get a sense of how it
all
went down you know how it all went down
and try to understand what the turning
points were
and why car nakamura is so dominant
nakamura i just want to say i've known
for a long time
and has always been his chest has always
been an enigma to me
and why because
he was always playing blitz from a very
young age
and everyone said naca you've got such
an amazing talent
why why is it that you're playing blitz
all the time like a maniac
don't you want to be studying the
classics don't you want to
have some super gm be your teacher this
is when he's a kid you know
and he's like no i just want to play
blitz online and
either you can say that
uh in fact you can get good with blitz
online or he's just super talented
obviously both
um i have a personal theory that has a
lot to do with his stepdad
sunil weirmantry who is still a great
chess coach in the new york city area
in any case i've never it never made any
sense to me that he got
as good as he got did he got to 2600
you know kind of early uh that was more
understandable but then
they made the jump you know into being
in contention
for one of the best um really
interesting now of course
in terms of winning what before
covet was the prize of everything which
was the world championship
classical which to me as a chess fan is
still the most interesting thing
i guess we'd have to say his time has
probably passed that's not going to
happen
however now it's almost as if
maybe that world championship classical
thing doesn't have the same cachet
the same currency that it once had and
now
like this blitz phenomenon going on
every day
it seems online is a much bigger day and
of course
naca has reinvented the art of chess
streaming the guy can talk
and do all kinds of stuff while he's
streaming playing good moves
and it's always been so weird to me that
he can find
good moves so quickly it's almost like
he's not thinking
that's one of the weirdest things he's
not thinking somehow he's just playing
the moves
so let's do this let's cruise through
some of these games
and just try to understand the art
of nakamura and also just ask the
question maybe fedex
was until clearly at some point you were
gonna after you lose three games in a
row you're gonna start being on tilt but
let's check it out so this is game one
this is played today
five five five minutes five second
increment
and here we go
very standard stuff
very standard stuff okay
this is all theory still
okay
now maybe this is a little unpleasant
for black
because of the c6 pawn okay so
we'll say out of the opening naka gets a
small
advantage okay
now actually i like i like that he
doesn't take the bishop i think a lot of
people would reflexively take the bishop
but then the queen just centralized and
the bishop isn't that hot anyway
and yeah it's actually it's already
really
uncomfortable i can imagine especially
uncomfortable on a blitz level because
if you play bishop b8
you don't really want to play rook bc7
after that that's really ugly
okay so still very solid position
and uh recently on the chess dojo we've
been talking about
boris gelfan's new book technical chess
and we're definitely going to get a
position here which is reminiscent of
that book where
black will have maybe one weakness
but probably not two and in my own
dogmatic sense of chess in the ending
you usually need two weaknesses to
actually get a winning position
the knight on d6 i'm sure naca's already
thinking about all kinds of tactics on
it
it's just a vulnerable piece
knight d2 beautiful just keep it just
keep it
vulnerable it doesn't have anywhere to
go
all right so black now commits
and boom
oh that's unfortunate isn't it
boom nice move so now if cd i assume the
intention is queen takes c8
which might be playable
maybe he should do it anyway he does
boom boom
boom actually fascinating position
whether it's blitz or not um
we actually talked about uh kind of
similar position
last night uh with the gel fan book
and i've always found these positions a
little bit um
scary because the rooks really do have
to coordinate
uh for white to get the advantage
right i feel like kramnik won a bunch of
games with the rooks
but no one else has been able to do it
and like if i was white here even if it
was a classical game i'd be worried
about bishop f4
that would be the thing i'd be worried
about okay
so here we go bishop f4 indeed
and naka's just going to say there is
nothing happening for black
very natural knight if queen b4 knight
f3
and probably g3 now yeah
okay so one of the amazing things about
naca is that
he has the ability to win this kind of
position
on a consistent basis is this position
winning i have a feeling someone like
kramnik would say this position is
winning
i don't i wouldn't trust myself
to say it's winning yeah
now i guess we gotta say it's winning
right
dang dang
oh now it's toast okay very
very instructive game and actually you
know you go back on it
there wasn't like a clear super blunder
by black right that's just a classical
game anybody could be proud of black
didn't do anything
funky really we can argue that his
opening was a little
uh wrong but you know
there's loads of gm games like this
where black has a small disadvantage
and you can say so what
nice move maybe he thought he could have
uh could have played queen takes you
know
maybe that was kind of what he was
thinking i mean this is going to be
unpleasant too
but i would say in this one like even if
you let's say here
so i don't know something like
oh there's there's weird actually you
know what there's weird tactics here
for example queen here
and imagine snip
let's just say i'm hitting the bishop so
you gotta play
no look at that queen d8 in fact would
have been the winner
because now we have queen h2 my friends
queen h2
excuse me bishop h2 freudian slip
because i'm winning the queen
queen d8 would have been a nice move
actually so that dc isn't even possible
oh yeah so in
these games obviously
the tactics like that are totally
critical and after gf as in the game
then he really is suffering i don't
like we said i mean that was a great
technique
all right let's look at game number two
again just to recap naca won
this first leg eight zero
eight zero i don't know you know you
think about fisher winning like six
oh this is like eight zero against a
very strong
player and let's go into game two
um yeah and then i think it
there were 27 matches 27 games and all
and
he had like 21 and a half you know
obviously
just anyway an amazing result today
so knock us black here
okay it's classical classical
i've played this myself as white
actually this queen c1 moves fun because
uh
you know there's all kinds of things why
i could do there like bishop g5 and such
but um josh fedele turned me on to queen
c1
as a move
okay these positions i want to say as
white as someone who's done this kind of
thing is white they
are amazingly tricky because
um not only is there all kinds of
uh positional stuff going on but there's
lots of nasty tactics and you could see
looks going to get some good squares
like night before and stuff and the only
worry asked he has really is like is
white going to be able to dominate some
of the miners with a move like e4
a little bit later and even then i've
had positions like that and it still
wasn't easy
okay now bishop d2 is obviously
uh a little controversial but he's
trying to say
that later i assume like i'm assuming
queen b1
like knight b4 queen b1 intending e4
yeah queen b1 i called it
right interesting position
so the achievement white can claim
is that yes black is preventing e4 here
but the knight on a6 is not hot
so i'm gonna guess rookie one yeah
bishop f3
and rook d-a fascinating
okay so this is all very tactical this
idea of vision f3 you get a lot in the
scandi and a lot of times scandinavian
bishop f3 and then c6 will happen with a
kind of similar structure
rook d8 is more testing because i'm
assuming the idea is something like
bishop b7
rook d4
okay he does do it
maybe this is a mistake oh i've okay
so knight c5 let's guestimate that he
missed
knight c5 what's nice about knight c5
too is that's the one piece that isn't
working
i think now we got to say white has to
be a little careful
that the thing that it all doesn't fall
apart this is exactly what i'm talking
about in these catalans
your position can become shaky and then
all of a sudden it's uncomfortable
and if we go back rook d8 was a nice
move
well the whole thing bishop f3 bishop f3
rook d8 because i think if e3
then c5 is gonna come and black is
beautiful
however it's not like he didn't have an
out he could have played bishop
e3 here so we're gonna i'm gonna guess
i was gonna say we're gonna guess but
you don't have to guess with me
that he missed knight c5
right
beautiful uh so right we have an
opposite color bishop ending the pawns
aren't going to matter much
and the dark squares are really going to
be nasty for black
yeah thank you very much thank you that
that's game
i think yeah this is just game all right
so
so let's say that came from a nice
shaky position and i can see
i've had stuff like that happen to me
and black
honestly doesn't have to be a genius a
lot of times you're just waiting for
white to make some kind of slip
and you know i'd
you know i don't know this might some of
this might i know the queen c1 is theory
but i don't know about bishop d2 maybe
he was still even in his theory then
all right let's go game three
again this is naca crushing fedo safe
today 8-0 in the five
plus five games actually if it's
i'm gonna check this i think it might be
five one five
one excuse me let me make sure i didn't
lose my board here
uh right so
let's get it messed up here come on cry
why'd you have to move the board buddy
why'd you have to move the board
you'd have to move the board all right
you know what
i'm just gonna manually fix this i will
never move the board again i promise you
guys i promise i won't do it
all right so here we are this is game
three
of this epic beatdown that naca gave
fedo safe today
so we repeat an h6
this honestly is like a modern chess
thing no one really believes in this
move
but as a blitz thing you know whatever
you could do it
okay so 95 is definitely not the first
move
that would come off to my mind but
i guess i'm going to guess the idea of
95 is to
initiate some kind of pillsbury attack
with f4
later let's see how it goes
snip okay so
bishop d6 i'm assuming knight
f4 would come and now knight c4 black
isn't that
you know i feel after h6 that he
deserves punishment
crime and punishment but now i think
black is okay probably a6
c5 first
do you have to take that thing he says
no i do not
he snips the light squares
and honestly let's just say black is
fine right white has the unopposed
bishop
that shouldn't be so bad
uh-huh now i will say
it's interesting uh
black's i think fine fisher did this
kind of thing too where
sometimes you get some position out of
the opening and your hope is just that
later the position is going to open
or your plan is that the position is
later going to open and the bishop will
come
to life
all right knock is just going to fool
around a little bit always repeat and
feta save
doesn't repeat and that might also
be not only because this position is
fine
but because uh
he's down 2-0 at this point and we'll
say
naka is a very slimy dude and i mean
that
i mean that in the best way
he will come up with 30 tricks to mess
with your head
and just because he repeats doesn't even
mean he wanted to draw
okay and right at this moment
um black has to be careful that not to
get be worse here with the bishop pair
[Music]
well now we got to say he's worse
yeah weak pawn better bishops
[Music]
very nice play finally
the same as round one where the bishop
on d6 is awkward
yeah just a little bit better let's say
the obvious uh
but white has one goal one need
and that is to fix the bishop on e1
now at least the bishop anyone's doing
something with knight g4
you know when you turn on the engine
position like this the engine is going
to say
uh all kinds of stuff uh like i i
eat both sides are making mistakes but
you know this is pretty much a working
here
and now i don't know probably again
probably a technically lost position the
kind of thing that a weak gm like myself
might wouldn't always convert uh
but knock a dude he's gonna bring it
here
is it true you had to give up the pawn
bro you had to give up the pod
wait a second queen a5
oh i didn't even realize that i take
everything back it's totally equal
so naca won this position man
oh no oh no that's sorrendo
like i told you he's a slimy dude i mean
honestly if i was in a blitz game i'd
rather
have the night just because they're
trickier dudes
no draw
yeah oh my god what happened here i'm
just going to blaze to this one
back and forth back and forth so he
blundered upon
oh no did he miss queen d4
oh horrendous okay
that was totally cruel totally cruel
all right so let's check it out
let's go to game four of this epic match
all right um wait am i on game four yeah
here we go so game four
feresev switches it up
plays the old-fashioned gioco piano
i was a grown man before i realized that
yoko piano
is actually quiet game it was hard for
me to understand
or believe because when i played the
joko piano it was full
madness as a kid anyway
i never played the slow stuff
okay
it's interesting position okay
you know this kind of thing actually has
always bothered me um
where white is saying of course that the
pawn on d4
is dominating the bishop on b6 and the
knight on d7
but it's black who's having all the fun
right
and so like in this position what he's
supposed to do he's supposed to play h3
to force matters
he does
oh no
it went the milk has gone bad
because he was if queen f3 bishop d4
got out tactic again man and now
i think well it's not i mean it's not
like an easy advantage for black but i
think after something like c5 we got to
say he's better right
jeez
very nice
oh no
cruelty ouch well this one's going down
my friends this is game four
you guys i want to say feta say if this
is not some chump
that decaro's taking down here this
guy's the real deal
and this is i mean this is over good
night
oh yeah how's this
king is too weak especially in a blitz
game
yeah ah
brutal all right so that was game four
this is one of the most epic beat downs
in blitz history i'm sure like there's
been matches online and stuff but in
terms of a blitz tournament
with like very strong players i don't
think i've ever seen this kind of beat
down
i can't remember if you guys know any
other beatdown of this scale
let me know all right it's game five 5
1 is the time control
again this h6 thing
okay
he gets the bishop on d6 in every single
game man all right
okay this time knock it takes i presume
that black could recapture both ways
but on cd the bishop on c1 will probably
end up on
a3 oh my good or what
am i good or what all right so kind of
in a funny thing about this match is the
d6 point
whether it was a bishop or a pawn is uh
the problem and this is this is
unfortunate
already here all white has to do is
figure out where to put the knight on a2
right if you figure out where to put the
knight on a2 that's it
and i don't know how you saw your d6
problems
e5 is the threat and we just got to say
f34
dominates the knight on f6 dominates the
bishop on b7
yeah it's funny you know sometimes knock
is such
one of the things reason's knocking such
an enigma to me is
he has a lot of snap judgments that you
know or so
when he makes him sound so profoundly
arrogant and self-assured
and i'm just saying that because i
imagine when he got this position he
just felt like he was winning
and this time i'm with him i i don't
think i don't see any way for black to
live through this thing
i take it back i mean you got you got
chances to live
you got chances to live
yeah so two games where the two bishops
uh
were dominant
nice move
oh yeah that's cold so knight d4 knight
f6
queen g6 queen g7 and it's yeah
it's a problem the bishops the bishops
are a problem my friend
so knight g4 x-clam
let's call this a french position with
no good bishop for black and a
terrible bishop on b7 he goes back
he massages
okay so how bad is this ending
this might be lost i don't know it's too
it feels too strong to say it's lost
however that bit the miners are so
terrible
good night oh god don't do it buddy
dang now the night's oh that's cruel
oh no
those pawns aren't going anywhere dang
oh man
oh sorry kid
resigns bishop b3 has fallen a2 is fun
really nice end game technique
create problems in the opening a little
bit of this and that
finish them off in the ending and that
was one of the questions i had when i
was thinking about
you know just what was going on this
match is like how does it happen
that you crush someone super strong 8-0
in any kind of match all right
so that was game five i believe and now
we're gonna go game six
from been true to their openings
same as last time
same as last time
same as last time okay same
and if i recall uh bishop b4 was played
the first time around right
okay actually excuse me queen b1 was
played instead of rook e1
okay queen b1 so we kind of transpose
now the knight is better
on b4 but it's this time this this is
the match if you could name this match
would be called the bishop d6 match
because now naka's got the bishop on d6
and if white has any advantage it's that
e4 e5
is a problem as well as just even if you
achieve e4
all of black's pieces are hoax hokie
so black needs a move to stop
e4 honestly this position
and we're going to see what naca did but
when i'm just looking at it i would
rather this is the position
i've played this a4 thing myself is the
kind of thing
that i would be happy with i always blow
it
because some terrible tactic happens to
me
that's probably what happened to fedex
safe here too
the famous bishop f3 trick c5
okay
it's also the tale of the two bishops i
want to believe that white's a little
bit better here
but something like c4 at some point
could really be a hassle
that's an ugly move i don't i don't know
buddy really you gotta do that
so funny how it happens like okay we get
this position i felt like
white is fine you know
black snips play c5
and the drama is that you got to worry
about c4
and you're trying to you know get some
points back but i mean
isn't dc what white should have done
you know it's still not clear exactly
what we're doing after that but
you know we can make some claim about
the bishops
what's odd is the queen on b1 doesn't
have any great squares to go to
and if the queen on b1 doesn't have
anything to do then you're going to do
end up doing something gross like rook
a3
so if i was going to just make a random
suggestion here dc followed by 94
feels like no i don't know black's you
know white soap may be a little bit
better
but e3 and now your bishop can't get out
you know ever k3 doesn't look right
and are you just lost now
oh no fantastia buddy
oh buddy i'm sorry bro i'm sorry
this is now to replay like the dark
square death is now on its way
oh oh no
just give it all to me give me all those
dark squares
oh oh he's not even he's not even gonna
let you have anything
nothing now it's just sicario doing
puzzle rush all day here
brutal brutal my friends that's a real
brutality and i imagine he's sitting
there at his house
he's streaming he's talking to people
he's like oh yeah
thanks for the 15 bits bro oh yeah you
know
oh i beat this jump back in the day or
something you know
just shooting all oh man
so everybody look at that that's a real
clinic
here we go uh let's do
round seven
we've seen it before
so for two games fed us they've did
early h6 and now we get this position
i'll just say this position my sense was
always that black is
fine you know because the dark square
bishop
uh should hold black's position together
i
i'm gonna say there's more than one way
for him to do this i
like he didn't have to take on c4 but
okay c4
it's a little weird to me what he's
doing
well we gotta say white's much better
the uh
bishop on c7 terrible that dark square
bishop
every single line he yeah he gets
getting persecuted
bishop d3 will happen someday uh
initiative against the black king
poor pawn structure
very standard business the bishop has
truly been a victim
right
just classical chess from acara as far
as i can tell
there again so maybe we'll get the two
rooks like in game one
all right he says no i don't want it
anymore
knight d4 and now the knight's going to
come to c6 and
uh it's going to be unpleasant i'm going
to guess that black was hoping that
white could not play knight d4
but on a positional level as long as
bishop b5 doesn't work
you're saying stuff like well if queen
h4 then knight c6 and i'm doing great
the bishop is again persecuted the dark
square bishop
that's exactly what happened
now how bad is it
i guess in part of the intuition as to
why this might be terrible
is with the opposite color bishops
it means the initiative will favor
uh well the the value of the initiative
will go up which white has
and the knight on c6 is obviously
amazing
dominating the rook on c8 no rook d8
so like black can't move
but i'm not sure i would say this is
oh man this might just be lost like what
happens it oh
okay so black's idea is if bishop c7
we can hopefully play queen g4 because
you got to cover e7
i don't know d3 is going to be a good
positional move anyway
game game
even i saw that oh man
but even though i saw it it's like i
don't know what he's supposed to do
about it
so right in this position
cd rook ca x exclam
if here well then it's just this one
right
oh it's not it's going to be mate it's
not just like some ending
it's going to be mate oh you guys
brutal so rook c8
knight d4 there's no bishop e5 because
of knight c6
imagine v5 knight c6 queen c7 95 queen
e5 bishop h7 hello
e5 toast
so and if you can't take on e5 what it
really means too is that bishop on b8
victim it's amazing how every single
game that
bishop has been made a victim um
and i'll just say it's ironic in the
particularly this opening system because
the part of the idea is that
we're sacrificing time black is with
bishop g5 and then h6 we sacrifice some
time to grab white's bishop
and in return we're supposed to have
this delicious dark square bishop but
it's not looking so delicious right now
and i guess we have to say that's just a
clean blunder
hard to give him some advice here but
that's a clean blender cause now boom
boom i don't even know what is he maybe
rookie eight is what he's gotta do
oh that's an ugly move
but i guess rookie eight maybe that's
what the computer would tell the guy to
do
totally vicious totally vicious all
right
game eight here we go
knock us black
all right we saw this once before
yeah these positions are always pretty
interesting to me
um like the last game
white's only chance at claiming an
advantage is going to be to play d4
to shut the bishop on b6 out but there's
going to be all kinds of nasty
counter shots uh
to interrupt that glory and you probably
want to play h3 right now to stop bishop
g4
okay and he does it
bishop b2 is an ugly move
so he feels he's got to do it because
put the bishop by it i mean putting the
bishop on a terrible square like b2
because
uh this d4 point is something
black is tickling
but already i don't i don't think uh i
don't i definitely want to be black
black again like this is the kind of
position where black has all the play
right now aggressive stuff is happening
yeah and i think you already have to say
black is better
because the bishop on b2 is so awful
yeah okay
yeah all right
we're getting a little something
cool as a cucumber all right so maybe
maybe white is better here this is the
first position out of the opening
i'm like maybe white's better i guess i
said that about the catalan position too
okay so you know that position he pulled
this off
boom all right
i mean looks beautiful what he's doing
it looks like white has an advantage
that doesn't feel like the move you want
to make
now maybe he has some idea that i don't
see yet
but let's just say you know
in general that he would want to play
something like g3
um and maybe i'm missing some tactic or
whatever but
yeah g3 you know just some building move
let's see what his intention with bishop
d5 is
he must steal a pawn
okay
so i guess we can say
that he stole his pawn and now naka
needs to find
some kind of juice
in this position
b6 okay so the knight is stopped
pawns are stopped maybe the queen runs
over
now did naca have some dirty trick after
knight f4
seems like that would have been the
first question
could white have played knight f4 maybe
it's king f7 after that was naka's idea
okay so naka of course
this is game eight and he's gonna win
this thing and i will say
this is a five one thing but they're
still like fedex on a mathematical level
isn't out of this tournament yet because
they get to play 3-1 after this and then
1-1
so it's not like he has to go totally
until
this position i guess to me it looks
like
maybe it's winning at the very least
it's clear advantage
the extra pawn at the moment that does
mean something because white can white
has
loads of good moves here he could play
for a plan with f4 f5 or he could just
break immediately with a5
i have a feeling the computer will
probably tell us that both are good
he goes the f4 now this is definitely
going to be
more uh dangerous because now our own
king is open
mm-hmm
and now if you play a5 right if you play
a5 now
his you know we got to worry about
naka's pieces swinging in
okay preventing a5
now you can obviously ask the question
how did the dude lose this game
and the first thing we got to say is
this position is going to be very hard
to win
very tough to win because it's going to
be hard to create the past pawn
and the black queen is going to start
playing pinball
down there on the inside of our guts
all right good uh threatening h5
black says no
and there it is it's very annoying in
these positions obviously white
shouldn't lose
but still now you got to deal with this
queen bouncing all around
well there's some simple questions right
there
oh i have a bad feeling about that a5
move
check the miserable king check the
miserable king
and now he's begging for a draw
oh man
so that's the classic case where
you don't have much anymore you got your
extra pawn you had your sense that you
were winning the game
and then things totally fall apart let's
go that's let's go
slow-mo on that one again
so like i said this one's hard white's
not doing anything
big here anymore if you play like queen
d2
there's going to be queen c4 and like i
said the pinball creation queen c1 is
coming real quick
and then what are you supposed to do
especially if you're going to try to win
the game
if you play a5 now unfortunately queen
d2
and queen a5 so there's nothing going on
there that's probably the idea of king
e2
and now he's touching d4 stopping a5
and then you got to deal with that
and it's honestly isn't it it's already
a little unpleasant for white
it's already unpleasant if you play
king c2 he's gonna play queen takes d4
no no terrible oh
it's already sorry the milk has already
gone bad here my friends
i don't know i'm gonna say that's now
lost i mean
you can play on but your pawns are just
like
they're terrible your queen doesn't have
any activity
oh man oh that's classic right there
brings bring it all in son bring it all
in
oh ouch ah
well guys that was a beautiful match uh
and i guess you know
nakadu that was that was showcase naka
style of what the guy's capable
and the blitz and it gets even more evil
when you go to
the uh faster time controls and maybe we
take a look
at those at summertime these games are
not live
uh but i'm just answering a question in
the chat
but they were played today so this is a
historic moment
naca beats fedexaf
and he was 21.5 out of 27 but more
importantly to my mind
wins the first leg of the blitz thing
today
five or with a five plus one segment
of eight games to zero absolutely
stunning
so it historic historic and we're gonna
be i don't know it's kind of a
interesting thing in terms of chess
culture because
this is maybe the new
the new big deal with the quick chess
and
naca streaming it makes it even a bigger
deal
and now especially for me as a chess fan
because i don't have any classical
chess world championship to
to be a fan of at the moment anyway all
right
so guys thank you very much i'm going to
be gm in residence here for the next
week or so
hope to see you around bye-bye